y hoy vengo a hablar de branding los que
conocéis lo sabéis y freddie mercury en
1985 compuso lo que es para mí la mejor
receta para cualquier marca que se
precie de serlo
voy a dar las gracias a los
organizadores para mí es un honor
compartir con vosotros esta tarde estos
minutos y sobre todo quiero dar las
gracias a todas las personas que veis en
la pantalla que son profesionales del
branding sin los que yo seguramente hoy
no estaría aquí porque ellos me
enseñaron la importancia de la emoción
la importancia del corazón en el mundo
de la marca de hecho como consultora que
soy este es mi mantra o mi propósito
recordar a mis clientes que si sus
marcas no pasan por el corazón de las
personas no son marcas ni son nada una
cosa importante porque aquí estamos
rodeados de economistas y yo soy que
esto a veces cuesta evidentemente que un
negocio ha de dar dinero pero como decía
el señor henry ford si sólo da dinero es
un mal negocio es algo bastante bastante
común a lo que me enfrento con posibles
clientes y yo vengo aquí a hablar de una
verdad verdadera que es que el branding
y el amor se parecen como dos gotas de
agua no sé si alguna vez lo habéis visto
así
yo que lo llevo muchos años practicando
es así vamos a hacer un poco de contexto
a ver si lo entendéis en primer lugar
los homo sapiens somos seres sociales
las redes sociales han llegado para
quedarse y no sólo eso sino que nos
gusta compartir yo lo llamo cuando me
enfrenta un nuevo cliente la prueba del
algodón
tendrás en las redes sociales de una
marca por supuesto también es su en su
web y enseguida te das cuenta si tienen
al cliente en el centro o como digo yo
ejercen el branding de postureo
por otro lado estamos inmersos en un
momento de máxima deshumanización
paradójicamente la humanizamos todo pero
los humanos estamos siendo yonkis de las
pantallas de repente los robots se nos
parecen los algoritmos deciden por
nosotros
hay máquinas que te hablan que no sabes
de dónde muy bien sale la voz y sin
embargo si queremos generar relaciones a
largo plazo debemos humanizar las marcas
esto se llama antropomorfos acción vino
es algo que yo me haya inventado ni
mucho menos sino que es una estrategia
que se lleva haciendo en el mundo
anglosajón desde finales de los años 90
y de la que soy ultra fan
por qué pues porque al final una marca
acaba convertida en un personaje en la
cabeza de todos nosotros pensar que la
mayoría de inputs los recibimos a través
de las imágenes sobre todo en esta época
de aui tan audiovisual y que las jóvenes
generaciones pues crecen evidentemente
más que leyendo leyendo imágenes
entonces al final la marca acaba siendo
un constructo mental que toma la forma
de un personaje con el cual nos
identificaremos o no en función de su
identidad
mirar esta imagen supongo que conocéis
de sobra los personajes
tenemos dos mundos distintos por un lado
tenemos a los homo sapiens sapiens en su
soberbia nos hemos autodenominado
doblemente sapiens cuando en realidad no
lo somos
dos primates que lo que nos une
resultará ser el 99 de nuestro adn y sin
embargo hay ese 1% que es muy importante
que nos separa pero que es una paradoja
porque nos hemos llamado a sapiens
sapiens cuando en realidad los animales
humanos somos los únicos que creemos y
no hay verbo más anti irracional que el
verbo creer como todos sabéis que sin
embargo fundamenta la existencia humana
en los los hombres creemos y este y esta
creencia o esta capacidad de creer en lo
que sea básicamente las religiones pero
en otras cosas es lo que nos diferencia
de los animales y además es muy
importante para el mundo de las marcas
veíamos a pedro con unas flores para
vilma y bueno intentando iniciar un
cortejo que esto también lo compartimos
con los mamíferos y como ellos decía
vengo a demostraros que el branding y el
amor se parecen mucho si no son
básicamente lo mismo estas son las fases
que yo he detectado en
en nuestras relaciones humanas lo que se
ha de dar para tener una relación a
largo plazo por eso el tiempo es muy
importante este es el proceso del amor
humano el proceso de branding es
exactamente el mismo pero esto pasa como
en la vida normal tú quieres tener una
relación a largo plazo con alguien pero
no con muchos aliens o sea el poliamor
en el mundo de las marcas no funciona y
en el mundo de las personas allá cada
cual esto qué quiere decir que no hay
marca que sea para todos si hay alguien
piensa que tiene una marca que puede ser
para todo el mundo
empezamos mal ni cocacola es para todo
el mundo entre otras cosas porque existe
ver si cola y además siempre habrá gente
que no le guste la cola una marca ha de
saber quién es su cliente o quien quiera
que sea su cliente ya los demás no pasa
nada por no querer los fase del
encuentro estamos aquí nos encontramos
igual vamos a ver si igual surge un
flechazo de momento nos tenemos que
encontrar si yo soy una marca lo primero
que tengo que hacer es comunica
comunicar porque todo recuerdo empieza
por un encuentro y por un conocimiento
no puedo recordar lo que no conozco
entonces toda marca ha de comunicar y
comunicar bien y no no existe la no
comunicación existe la mala comunicación
y yo siempre añado existe sobre todo la
mala educación es si te preguntan no
contestas como marca si te dicen algo en
redes tampoco es decir al final un mail
sin contestar no hay es que no lo he
visto es que estoy muy ocupado es que
esto no es relevante esto no importa
pero a la persona que te lo enviado sí
porque se ha tomado su tiempo no
reclamación de atención al cliente lo
que sea es decir cuando lo contestamos
estamos siendo con perdón mal educados
nos encontramos y nos olfateamos como
hacen a veces los los animales y tú
quién eres
tú que no qué haces ni para quién lo
haces no dime tú quién eres marca que
representas qué quieres qué personalidad
tienes qué identidad
explícame sobre ti muchas veces las
marcas lo que hacen es explicar
qué hacen y para quién lo hacen pero no
dicen nunca quiénes son
por qué pues porque la mitad de ellas
más un cuarto de la otra no tienen una
hoja de ruta en mi caso yo lo llamo un
brand book que es el el libro de la
marca como su nombre indica que es donde
se plasman todos los valores la
personalidad del propósito de la marca
el tono de voz etc etc etc seguro que
algunos os suena pero no basta con
tenerlo en movimiento se demuestra
andando y un valor es una conducta si tú
esto no lo compartes con tus equipos y
por supuesto después de puertas hacia
afuera esto sigue siendo branding de
postureo importante cuando tú tienes un
brand book es decir tienes la identidad
de marca bien clara escrita con su ética
y su estética porque no hay ética sin
estética es importantísimo esto para las
marcas independientemente de su
categoría las opiniones no no al lugar y
yo esto se lo he dicho desde a un
presidente un director general y un
director de marketing es decir el
criterio es la coherencia con la
identidad de la marca
y esto que quiero decir que
inmediatamente cuando tú tienes un gran
boom y obviamente el brand book ha de
venir facilitado o consentido por arriba
el presidente director general máximo
responsable y por lo tanto ha de caer
hacia abajo esto inmediatamente tienes
una herramienta de gestión una
herramienta de gestión que te permite
tomar decisiones en menos tiempo y sobre
todo y los que pertenezca y eso tengáis
empresas familiares me entenderéis mejor
sin subjetividad si el que se ha
levantado y todo está a topos y quiere
pintar de rosa a la sede y ponerle unos
topos los amarillos pues no gracias en
la identidad la la marca la marca no
eres tú la marca es como un hijo que se
tiene se alimenta se cuida tendrá rasgos
tuyos pero la marca no eres tú no te
equivoques
además hay una cosa muy importante o
incluso casi más importante la marca son
lo que piensan tus clientes sobre ella o
tus audiencias la marca siempre es una
realidad subjetiva perdón y el cliente o
la audiencia nunca se equivoca nunca
votamos mal si no somos percibidos como
marca como deberíamos es que estamos
haciendo mal nuestro trabajo de
comunicación porque además esta realidad
subjetiva depende de dos cosas primero
de la experiencia de la marca que yo
puedo tener en cualquier punto de
contacto y ahora por desgracia para las
marcas cada vez son más no solo las
redes sino las páginas web el boca-oreja
el proceso de compra etcétera etcétera
primero esa experiencia y después lo que
me ha generado esa experiencia es decir
la percepción y no sólo hablo de
atención al cliente con lo cual esa
forma en mi cabeza una opinión un
sentimiento mejor dicho qué va a pasar o
no va a pasar por el corazón no he dicho
antes pero yo me defino siempre como
fundamentalista del corazón me imagino
que ya entendéis un poco por dónde voy
otra etapa es el deseo aquí está el
meollo o hay rechazo o no lo hay pues
esto es igual que la vida misma para que
haya flechazo me tienes que interesar
tengo que encontrar que tienes algo que
me atrae si no me atrae estamos
fastidiados una marca sin significado no
generará deseo si no significa para
alguien es que la triste realidad es que
es insignificante y quién quiere ser hoy
insignificante ser insignificante quiere
decir morir no sé si sabéis que a más de
al 81% de las personas las marcas le
importan nada
y yo me incluyo trabajando en ellas
claro no me importan las que no
significan las que no las que no me
pasan por el corazón sin deseo nunca
habrá venta de nada ni relación es decir
si a mí no me gustas por mucho que tú
quieras yo no te voy a hacer mi caso y
evidentemente no te voy a tirar los
trastos otra cosa importantísima es que
obviamente en este proceso del cortejo a
quien no le gusta sentirse especial como
son los buenos en las buenas las
personas que nos encontramos que nos
hacen sentir especial sobre todo si nos
gustan a quien no le gusta sobre todo
además cuándo a cambio estamos pagando
nuestro dinero
es decir que ya me puedes hacer la
pelota ya me puedes llamar guapo guapo
ya me puedes hacer que me sienta
especial y bien en también en todos los
puntos de contacto lo cual por cierto no
es fácil lo reconozco pero no es
imposible hay marcas que lo hacen muy
bien y en la primera manera de saber si
esa marca está o no está por ti es lo
que se llama el propósito que ha dejado
obsoletas esas cosas tan corpore y
además tan pasadas ya
de moda en el emotional branding que es
la misión y la visión si alguna de
nuestras marcas tienen visión y visión
por favor revisarlo porque eso ya no ya
no ya no funciona es un micro manifiesto
es una frase que te ha de seducir al
primer vistazo normalmente te deberías
tropezar en tu página web
obedecer a la regla de las tristes clara
concisa y sobre todo contundente porque
concisa ojo debería caber en menos de
160 caracteres cuanto más corta mejor
deseo seducción vale empezamos ya a
conocernos y bueno vamos a tener una
historia estupendo muy bien todos lo
hemos practicado la seducción
obviamente en una marca sin las personas
en el centro olvídate
por desgracia me encuentro que tengo que
darle la razón a una de las personas que
ve y es al principio que es philip
kotler que supongo algunos conoceréis
uno de los grandes padres del marketing
actual que siempre dice que el cliente
nunca es lo primero y yo estoy
absolutamente de acuerdo con él por
muchas razones el cliente pasa siempre o
casi siempre al segundo plano con lo
cual no está en el centro de la marca y
sin el cliente en el centro de la marca
vamos mal que quiere decir la seducción
desde desde el punto de vista de una
marca pues lo primero que tienes que
hacer como en la vida real imagino y
ahora no tengo tiempo para preguntarnos
cómo seducir pero lo primero es que te
tienes que interesar por la otra persona
tienes que intentar conocerla saber que
le gusta que no que puede necesitar que
es que le puede gustar es decir tienes
que conocer de nuevo a tu cliente si las
personas en el centro no hay nada y esto
al final que significa pues lo mismo que
la vida misma un gran trabajo
de día a día de picar piedra cada día
cada día es como una relación si en un
matrimonio uno de los dos deja de
seducir al otro deja de picar piedra que
pasará a la corta oa la larga pues que
se divorciarán normal pues con los
clientes pasa lo mismo porque el amor no
es incondicional claro mi perro me
quiere yo soy los hay todo pero los
clientes no somos mascotas los clientes
somos cada vez más exigentes y sabemos
perfectamente cuando una marca nos
quiere o ha nacido para querernos o no
nos quiere otra cosa es que sigamos
comprando otra cosa es que no nos
quejemos porque ésta es otra el 96% de
las personas descontentas con una marca
lo que hace es tirarse largarse y no
deja ni rastro yo soy de las que me
quejo intento dar ocasiones para mejorar
claro y además así veo cómo funcionan
pero la mayoría de los clientes cuando
tienen una queja lo que hacen es
largarse y no volver bien hemos
conectado fantástico
ahora tenemos que ponernos desde el
punto de vista de una marca ostras nos
han comprado
comprar una marca no es un gesto
inocente es como ir a votar estás
votando por una y dejando de lado
muchísimas más y esto hay que tenerlo en
cuenta a los humanos hemos visto antes
las redes sociales nos gusta conectar
por lo tanto nos gustan las marcas que
nos hacen conectar que nos escuchan que
nos que empatizan con nosotros que nos
dan cosas que necesitamos que son
interesantes porque luego es verdad que
los contenidos que generan muchas marcas
son un auténtico peñazo siempre
compramos marcas o utilizamos marcas que
están de acuerdo con nuestra identidad
bien que estén de acuerdo con ese yo
real que todos llevamos dentro como nos
percibimos o bien y esto es importante
también nuestro yo ideal que todos
llevamos dentro que es cómo nos
percibimos en relación a los sueños oa
las aspiraciones y necesidades que
tenemos es una herramienta que viene de
la psicología y siempre siempre siempre
compramos marcas o utilizamos marcas que
refuerzan cualquiera de nuestras dos
identidades que las dos son igualmente
válidas el secreto de la buena
mental está en saber cuando estás con tu
yo ideal y cuando estás con tu yo real
de hecho una marca hoy en día es una
co-producción y muchas marcas grandes lo
habréis conocido no juegan justamente a
integrar a sus clientes dentro de lo que
se llama el gran relato o el
storytelling de la marca
haciéndoles partícipes de manera que se
conviertan en acciones memorables si lo
hacemos bien el premio será la fidelidad
como en un buen matrimonio si estamos
satisfechos seducidos y sentimos deseo
nada es para siempre ninguna marca
exitosa hoy va a ser exitosa seguramente
de aquí 20 años no te puedes dormir en
los laureles y yo sé que esto es difícil
es difícil en el día a día frenético de
toda la compañía implementar el branding
es una tarea más que se añade al día a
día frenético como os decía y que tiene
que no parar nunca no todas las empresas
son una marca es decir por tener un
nombre y un logo no eres marca porque
por tener un nombre y un logo puedes
vender cosas pero no te aseguras pasar
por él
las personas hoy te puede ir muy bien
sin hacerle mucho caso a la marca pero
yo he visto en el panorama de más
español y en la categoría donde me muevo
básicamente que es el mundo de la moda
que lo han pasado muy mal justamente por
no tratar el tema de la marca entonces
la fidelidad no es para siempre tampoco
si tú te sientes a gusto con una marca y
alguna vez se equivoca pues seguramente
primero si te resuelve bien te va a
fidelizar más y después se lo vas a
perdonar con lo cual en una marca ha
nacido para querernos y yo creo que es
lo más bonito que os puedo decir porque
al final una marca es que es un
intangible al final una marca es
personas en un lado trabajando por ella
personas delante trabajando para no
trabajando sino comprando lado
relacionándose con ellas y al final yo
creo que al final es hablar de los
corazones que nos importan no tanto por
un lado como por el otro
gracias